Signs are everywhere.
Signs are on posts.
Signs are on buildings.
Signs are in windows and on doors.
They hang above streets.
Where else do you see signs?
Signs tell us lots of things.
Signs tell us what to do.
They tell us when to walk and when not to walk.
They tell us when to stop and when to go.
Signs tell us where to go and where not to go.
They tell us how far to go and how fast we can go.
What do these signs tell us?
Signs give us warnings.
They warn us about children playing.
They warn us about animals on the road.
They tell us to drive slowly on winding roads.
What do these signs warn us about?
People make signs for lots of things.
They make signs for sales.
They make signs for lost animals.
People make signs to advertise things.
What other things do people make signs for?